hello everyone I love the energy here
because if you guys were here last year
or if you are lucky enough to go to
amazing at comic-con Aloha in Hawaii you
probably know I am a huge power rangers
fan my name is Perry Nemiroff I work for
Collider where the media partner here so
if you haven't already done so check us
out on YouTube or a collider.com
but to be here yet I thought last year
when I got to host this panel it was
like a fluke it was a one-in-a-million
chance and I was so happy and so excited
and then all over again when they asked
me to come back and not just moderate a
panel with Jason David Frank but we also
have Amy Joe Johnson here this year as
well which is so exciting I already see
the clock on the screen and I'm not
going to waste any time here so please
give a big round of applause for Amy Joe
Johnson and I see Jason David Frank
right behind her so please show them
some love right now hello hello did we
miss our cue sorry about that
it was later catching on traumatic in a
while you had to build the suspense as
you walked up cute this one is oh what
an outfit this guys hanging out your
shields I know how that is hang on a sec
I don't hello everybody in the back
skirts I think there's there's some
seats if you guys want it there's some
empty seats over there if you guys want
to sit down or you know I'll have to
come on in guys it's good to be back
okay hi oh it's so it's always a little
bit weirder doing it in the middle of
the convention room no yes
these lights are intense too it makes it
feel extra official all right how are
you guys doing
[Applause]
nice to see ya alright so we're gonna
jump into a Q&A now but we are gonna
open it up to questions from the
audience at the end so I'll let you know
when to start lining up but do that and
you guys can ask these two some
questions to start here I believe you
have a new video coming to your YouTube
channel today right what's that you have
a YouTube video you're gonna launch
today can you tell everybody about that
one it's the the JTF spoken truth series
that i've been doing oh hey guys I did
four episodes this one's called mental
prison that I was in the hotel like
trying to download it in the internet
kept like man I was like darkness
Internet's around all times when you
need it but it's called mental prison
just I've been writing poems for a long
time we've been producing them and it's
the fourth one I just did my fifth one
which is more of a short film it's a six
seven minute long short film it's
interesting but uh but yeah that was
called mental prison and when I was
looking at all the the teeing up you had
done on Instagram in YouTube for that
video I also revisited some ninja
material because you posted a video so
this is a great webseries that you
should check out they basically had an
itty-bitty budget and just made the most
out of it the action is incredible you
posted a video of that shot where a
blood shot gets the knife through the
mouth so I am very big into horror and
gore and how you achieved that on screen
so I was wondering if you could break
that down for us a little exactly what
you needed to do to make that happen
well the ninja versus Val universe I
play blood shot in there and the blood
shot films already filmed I saw the
trailer with Vin Diesel looks really
good by the way
that's gonna be out in February they've
already shot that whole film but you
know so I did the bat in the Sun version
of it which was fun and most of stuff as
you know FX like just special effects
you know like it looked like this huh
and then later they'll put the knife in
the blood and everything but I did have
blood in my mouth so yeah I just got
stabbed in the face he's blood shot so
it's on my youtube channel JD f FF in
for now until Sony pulls it off sticking
with a genre right now I hate to do this
to you but after our conversation at the
Hawaii con you know what I wound up
watching I have no idea i watch can you
talk
a bit about how your other movies going
I know you do it had directed another
feature and considering how I felt about
your last one I'm jiggered to see it
yeah so I've been writing and directing
for the last five years which has become
my passion and it's like really all I
want to do so I did a feature film
called the space between two years ago
and I actually it was really great
because I was able to to make the film
because of an IndieGoGo campaign was
anybody part of the IndieGoGo campaign
in the space between that guy what about
me I mean you but and you were anyway
it's my first poem that I wrote and
directed it's called the space between
did anybody see some flash point was it
TV series I did a flash point okay okay
thanks yeah so that a lot of the actors
from that show or in the space between
two and it's a it's a heartfelt comedy
and I'm quite proud of it and if you
have a chance you can watch it on iTunes
or a bunch of different platforms and I
highly recommend it anyway and then I
just recently just finished shooting my
second feature film called Tammy's
always dying and it stars Felicity
Huffman and that'll come out in about a
year right now we're in post right now
so I'm doing the the color and the music
and it's like each phase of filmmaking
is so you learned so much right she
actually the short film I'm doing is
probably I have two short films the Omni
boat that I did a long time ago that's
finally got picked up being being
produced and finished and that was a
short film because I was talking to Amy
before she's like yeah you know just do
some short films and I was like yeah you
know what's the point of short films
when is that
well the Omni boat with Robert Redford
and Adam Devine the one I was talking
about a link to it early
yeah so Sundance that's what they're
hoping for
they did get offered another thing but
they turn it down but I'm hoping because
Robert Redford's in it and his nephews
producing it so maybe fine so I did that
and then I did another short film that's
called in my head it's like my poem
stuff but I played eight different
characters is mostly that Albert one of
my I couldn't I played eight different
roles and we were we were you know you
know as a director we had a round table
so when we would turn around we'll just
turn it around and then I was like okay
well I'm not JDF now I'm this guy that
guy
so just watching the lines and little
like that so it's yeah so I did that
just because I think in short films you
can like you know show a different side
of you or acting stuff so we talked in
Canada a long time ago about that when
we were doing the film and I remind me
of Flashpoint when you guys raise your
hand we were in Canada we were on a
nondisclosure agreement and we were
talking and kind of dinner someone but
anyway some fans came up and they're
like fan oh hey how you doing oh my god
I looked last point I'm like oh we're on
on NDA and I know we haven't been
together 15 years someone's gonna take a
picture and all the stuffs gonna go on
they're like hey I love your show excuse
me sir can you and I was like me I was
like yeah take a picture so I was like
goddamn really like say anything to me I
was like ready
one drink Cooper yeah I was like one two
three boom there we go it was awesome I
don't even know do the cameo so I flew
out and I hadn't seen Jason in like ten
years and we get there and we went and
had dinner in this restaurant at the
hotel the day before we went to shoot
the cameo and then somebody came is I
don't know why I thought it was so funny
but they came up and they asked Jason to
take a picture of me and this guy I
thought it was funny I was like the
whole time the whole time yeah I wonder
now if they know like oh you took a
picture so weird it's it's so strange
though I have a quick story and I move
on about taking a picture I was doing a
comic-con with Jason who you know
Aquaman and and so I was doing a
comic-con swear they spray-painted like
Jason on this Haute
you know wasn't my name but I thought it
was but I was like oh wow
really cool and then I put up a little
JDF in my window like haha you know like
I put a little JTF in the window
11:15 at night I hear this knock on my
door knock-knock-knocking I'm like so I
open the door how's it gonna say man I
know super late man can you take a
picture and I was like yeah man yeah and
I kept doing this to the guy he's like
man and I was like you take pictures
yeah bro here's my camera
we're totally drunk I just randomly
knocked on a door if you could just take
that picture bro and then I took the
picture and I went there you go and he's
like thanks and I closed my door when he
said can I take a picture I thought he
meant with me but he's like hey bro can
you take a picture and I was like yeah
he's not doing your hotel just a random
door random person random door says can
I take a picture and I was like trying
to put my hand on it he's just like bro
here here's my camera take a picture
anyway that's why remind me so I'm glad
cuz they didn't see he didn't say
anything I wonder now if he knew what
the heck but they're like I love you
totally excuse me totally love you a
flash point this is just nothing us
power ranger stuff like nothing
questions just flash points that was
funny picture by speaking of folks
getting photo opportunities with you
guys I really wanted to ask you about
your experience on the con circuit
because still it doesn't matter how many
conventions I've been to the fact that
this exists like it just it filled my
movie and TV loving heart so so much and
the way I want to get it is I was
watching your pitch video for the
husband and I wanted to know what
happens next you're also talking about
IndieGoGo financing before
did that ever pan out because I watched
the video and there's just something
about it that it I don't know it seemed
to me like you were building towards
some sort of like like a warmth and a
real appreciation for what has been
created over the years and I wanted to
see it well so I was anyway I was
developing a something that I'm not
developing anymore I decided I didn't
want to do it but anyway to go back to
what you were saying about the con world
I so I maybe three years ago was when I
started doing my first convention
honestly like people have asked me do
you have you realized like the impact
that Power Rangers is head on people and
I hadn't until three years ago when I
went to my first convention and I've
just found it fascinating and amazing to
see and hear stories from so many people
and start to realize like if the impact
that this show had on on people on kids
who are now adults like so many of you
that you know it when we were in our
early 20s doing the show had no I mean I
had no idea how it was helping and
influencing so many kids and people did
you agree I think when we started and
the first thing just back it up to Las
Vegas not only are we at Comic Cons
we're in Vegas here at a Comic Con which
to me Jimmy runs a great show to
actually be in Vegas to go to a Comic
Con there's like millions of things to
do so when I was like Vegas I wonder
Comic Cons but then I was like wow I had
a millions of things to do in Vegas we
appreciate you guys coming here you know
which is super cool like I'm blown away
by that I used to come to Vegas
everyone's like well how you like Vegas
I'm like son I've been coming to Vegas
before you were born
I've been coming to Vegas here since I
was like five like every weekend there
is so much to do there is a lot so when
they said Comic Con I was driving by all
these bigs to iearn thinking this and
that so I'm happy and gem runs probably
only show in Vegas that can actually
succeed and be successful because of the
fans but I don't think we were able to
hear the stories because you guys are
kids and sometimes I hate saying that we
never listen to kids you know they well
you know they're talking about the first
crush or the boyfriend the girlfriend or
how bad you know broke their hearts and
all that stuff but we didn't see that
until you guys were older to be like man
that really hurt me man you know cuz
that an eight nine year old they're like
okay all right bud go play and you're
like but I'm sad you know and I watched
Jenna watch this wizardly world thing or
whatever was early place or something
like that right is that the name of it
you know is that why are you laughing
then so someone lost their powers and
Jenna was like really super sad about it
and then I look
and I said I wonder if that's how kids
felt when I lost my powers you know I
wonder if that's how you felt when
someone broke up with me you know it was
moving for you guys so now we're able to
hear the stories because you don't have
to you still listen to mom and dad but
you're your own individual you can go to
comic-con be like I'm by toy you don't
have to tell me I don't have to watch
the show watch it in you guys are rebels
yeah well and for me it was just the I
like I didn't understand at the time
because for for me probably for all of
us it was sort of the college years
instead of being in college I was
shooting Power Rangers so we were
focused on you know having a good time
and hanging out and partying a bit and
stuff and and really the impact that it
had I didn't realize until about three
years ago but it's been so great because
of just people like growing up with us
through my my career as an actress and
now transitioning into writing and
directing and it's just really great you
guys didn't know I was writing directing
I'm writing and directing now and I
really got you guys follow you guys know
yeah you follow the pages and all that
stuff space between you watch it yeah
but anyway it's uh it's nice to have
that support system of people that sort
of grew up with you and the other great
thing about it is you know when like
you're in high school and then you don't
see a high school friend until like
thirty years go by and then you see them
but then they're old but they don't look
old because you only see the person from
high school that's what I feel like guys
like people like oh you look so young
there's a picture I was gonna tell you
that I saw on Instagram you look to say
there's in this picture I was wondering
you like the only one someone put like a
group shot of all of us you probably see
it and I know but I was looking at it
and I was looking zooming in I mean I
got a beard and I I have to show you in
your picture I had to like really zoom
in it wasn't natural picture from a
comic-con I think it was almost the same
position I'll show you you look I'm
nervous
I promise I'll have to show you it's a
picture that someone put together of all
of us
and I'll show you I mean as you talk
I'll show you but she look the same I
was reading all the comments cuz I was
like I wonder if people gonna say that
she's looks the same should we do
questions do you guys want to start
lining up I would suggest you line up
ten at a time so they don't get like
cutoff towards the end you know
hopefully we can get a mic right in the
middle here and we can take a whole
bunch of questions so hop on line now if
you guys could give one piece of advice
for a concert at first time or someone
who's just gonna start doing what you
guys are doing now what would it be
oh oh I don't know I would probably just
do ten at a time but okay we don't want
to get cut off I think just be yourself
and be there for your fans and you know
enjoy it out I guess cuz if you don't
know the comic-con world don't offend
them by trying to guess their
character's name because you will offend
them you just say that's cool cuz
they're like that's not the animation
like sorry or or the worst was or I was
where was a couple weeks ago in Phoenix
and I was sitting next to this guy this
lovely man who was on the office and
some guy comes up and he goes I loved
you on that show and and the guy was
like oh thank you and then he goes I'm
just kidding I've never seen it don't do
that that's not nice that was the worst
I don't know it was really mean all
right what's the first question down
there
hi oh so my name is Rob I'm from
Baltimore been difficult to finally get
to a calm where both of you guys were
add so it's a pleasure to finally see
you guys big fan my question is deep
when you guys were shooting Power Ranger
did you have a specific episode that was
your favorite to shoot or any fun really
favorite experiences that you guys had
because my personal one of my favorite
episodes were when you guys were running
for class president that was
my favorites but I wanted to know do you
remember that one I seen it on Instagram
have we've done so many of them but I
remember I was like why it was the one
when you had to kiss me right
no that wasn't that one that was my was
it I kissed her in that one only kitchen
more on that we're in next to the lake
that wasn't the other he's talking about
is it yeah the one where you guys I was
running for office she's trying to put
corruption in there she hears politics
she's like us you know the corruption
and the politics
what was your you said you had a
favorite was it the I liked with David
Yost I always got to like do something
turn evil or something like that
I always enjoyed that part just the
honesty man the first day showing up the
set like that one not that one I wasn't
nervous though cuz I didn't know like
what is it like Daryl I don't know what
kind of kiss like what didn't they say
but you know I don't know I never kissed
anyone on TV so I didn't know what to do
I wasn't really stressed out tongue and
everything I was like come on no I did
not look at the little kids just
frightened over here my first day on set
remind me of this like bright lights I
didn't really know what was going on I
leaned on like one of the command stairs
and it rolled and I was like man like
nothing gonna go that's for set
turnarounds no clue what he's talking
about okay everything was just fake and
I was just like big green screen and
like there's auradon I didn't know what
it was talked to the tape and I was like
okay Saul these guys I was like the new
guy coming in they were kind of already
filming I remember walking past all
these sets and I was like just behave
yourself and be good just get through
the day and you did it look at you now
you are myself up the mayor of questions
never heard that one like the
what's your what's your name is your
question my name is Lee tree I'm so
happy to be here to me these guys cuz
they're my favorite and I want to meet
them as a kid but I never got to come to
comic-con so it's my face to comic-con
nice to meet you you're still a kid
though aren't you yeah but I mean okay
well as younger my question is for JDF
what you guys do when it got really hot
when you're in the apartment cost in
those costumes um you know there was a
lot of Japanese footage that we had you
know so what about the Australia in
Australia those ones you just go like
this man you just go I get through it
alright cut cuz we couldn't pee and
those ones either okay I think well you
can't pee in it but it was hard to like
it took like an hour to like put it as
the Green Ranger even with the shield
and all these things like can't someone
just create a little zipper they have
him now but just a zipper just one for
me cuz like for them you know they can
take their clothes but I had to like Oh
take this off take that off take my
shield off - yeah so I just held it
that's why I've trained myself to hold
it ten hours straight
I never forget a real talent William
Shatner I was in the back room and
William Shatner says yeah you don't pee
much on these conventions and I said no
he goes here's how you practice squeeze
stops okay next I swear to god it was
and I was looking at Shatner I was
looking at Shatner's eyes and I was
saying why am i doing what he's saying
right now it was so weird I promise to
God go and one squeeze you know learn
and I was like why evils yeah I was
squeezed in and I was like why am i
listening don't do that too much because
you could hurt yourself
and he's going 1 & 2 and I'm doing it
finally I was like this is weird like
that's very strange I look to my
comic-con see we all do it together now
because everyone will it's a whale you
just do it it's in your brain it's just
everyone's doing it now trying to stop
stop just you guys stop it
no more kegels alright next question
this is weird
we're going down here out alone thank
you Hey well um this is my second year
CJD average yeah nice
hence it first I'm seen a me so high Oh
question for both of you and this is
kind of regarding Abby's more first
crossover are you two possibly making
like a cameo appearance in that
crossover by any chance
niya beats more first yeah the new
beastie my first beast amorphous know
where that's what that's really steamed
or else be Stevie B's nobody the Sun is
beating down on my baseball morphin time
let me see more verse not beasty Obispo
Austin's in Johnson no I don't think
it's a cameo I think he's an actual
Ranger nope oh maybe I was I mean it's a
cameo but I'm sure he's the Ranger oh I
don't know
so like not gathering all the Rangers
wandering one episode anything like that
that'd be too hard dude there's a lot of
them how many are there you guys
probably like a hundred or something for
the hundred range 100 is something right
oh my god those are like like a musical
how many Rangers in 26 seasons wait
gathering them all and then singing a
song together like all in costume that
will go viral what would you sing the
theme song I don't know take your
helmets off man is singing not with your
helmets on good question Amy sings to
you all know that too right yeah
yeah hi there I'm Travis I've been to
these conventions for many years now
always wonder did you guys get to keep
any your old costume or props from the
show like you haven't like a shelf at
home or something
the only you did yeah
the only thing I have is the little coin
yeah I got a lot of stuff dragon dagger
I've got my Green Ranger suit I got a
bunch of stuff how do I know that did
they know you have it I wasn't really
stealing it was just kind of like it's
fell in my bag I'm like whoa weird like
and then I felt so bad like I think I
could take it back sleep but they did
call me on the reunion and Jonathan's
like Jason no I need your suit no really
like we don't have much do you have any
props and I was like I don't know he's
like just tell me I won't get mad I mean
we need them if you have your
communicator I bet you didn't know I we
made a new spandex one at it but I but
but I saved that one too I took that one
too so I'm like doubling up on him but
here's the thing because Disney when
they did every season Disney would
destroy the props literally destroyed
the props so no one will have him and
when Saban got it back they have nothing
so that's such a bummer do you remember
one season when the guy I was dating he
was a grip and they stole the Blue
Ranger suit and the whole grips are the
electric team they and they all got
fired I have that suit I blamed him you
got one man you gotta be like dude he
stoled it no I wasn't me but I do
remember that but yeah they put the
stuff on one you know because you get
them all the time at these conventions
when you post pictures of them and
they're beautiful yeah I got the Lord
that lord jacket one I sent it to to get
it done and that Louie Vuitton stuff
he's a great artist he's done like but
yeah I miss six I mean I don't buy them
at conventions but I've had them I don't
have a Aniki I usually have a Nicky's
helmets but as far as helmets I only
have one which is the dinosaur somebody
made them yeah I have one from the show
in the whole diner thumb show the whole
Dino Thunder suit how do I pull that
that hanging in your house my dojo this
is so cool there any one thing you guys
have been gifted a tack on that I mean
I'm sure you get things from adoring
fans all the time and is there anything
that's kind of like this centerpiece at
home that you see that and it really
kind of touches you to have that memory
I don't I don't know I know I did get a
figurine that when you press the back
it's actually my voice that says
something it's my voice so I like that
sometimes I put the toys on my it's not
my voice and like say something like we
got a lot of different things I usually
take pictures or I have it's just a
whole room full of stuff you don't make
some really good you guys make really
good props more than we had on the show
our suits were like 50 pounds but they
were made of rubber tire like literally
tire like shaved tires and painted so
they didn't have a VA phone back then we
used like rubber tires there sold so hot
so hard to go so long ago that's why you
just go to the bathroom in them
yeah it's wet I don't know he stole the
blue costume sir
now his dreams are shattered what's your
question crossovers what's your most
favorite pairing is crossover cuz I can
name Korea for myself you name three
quickly okay the one with the time of
thunders one ninja storm no that's
number three okay number three go to
more legit was lost galaxy and the
Rangers in space okay what's your number
one my friend number while with the
Ranger his face team up with the Ninja
Turtles I'm pretty sure I y'all would
remember that sort of I think favorite
crossover I don't know what it is just
like in people's imaginations or does
this really happen
on the show they had a ninja turtles on
the show no really yeah they had a
crossovers we weren't on there though No
different season the crossovers I mean
that the crossovers I only was done like
the Beastie Boys when the Beastie Boys
did boy yeah
the Beastie Boys no the probably ninja
steel and Dino Thunder for me I don't
think Amy would did crossovers it would
you have to be part of different yeah
all right next to it did take the one
hey my name is Mark from Apple Valley
this person is for both of you um if you
could go back to the Mighty Morphin
series what is one thing you would
change a wouldn't change about the way
you took the characters I probably get a
girlfriend what you said I said having a
girlfriend I'd like that part I change
all I want to change anything I think
Tommy getting him a girlfriend I think
was great
Amy for you um I don't know I've never
even thought of anything like that what
would I change about Kimberly if you
could or would change I think
breaking his heart may be changing first
of all I had asked to leave the show and
so they wrote me they don't know you do
know do you know so know half of them
think I'm Kim no I'm kidding
I'm Amy Jo guys I'm just kidding
and then I asked to leave the show and
then so they wrote me out and to do that
it was like passing a baton and then
Katherine was gonna play the pink ranger
and in the way I was my rebound but she
worried it right
she got my mind off you but she worked I
mean it's just life guys but she got but
she got the mind off of all right you
are not Tommy you are G but I was saying
if I was Tommy if you were talking if I
was kids watching so they wouldn't be so
they died so they need it too like don't
hate her that's what you're saying
kids notice you got you made it I think
I know I would not probably change the
girlfriend book
it's kinda you know the what-if
questions are so hard for me because
when I used to say that in my karate
school as a four and five year old my
instructor who played morning mortal
scorpion in the Mortal Kombat movies and
Tony knows because you ran one of my
schools we say what if and they say what
if your aunt was your uncle
keep punching I'd be like what it could
have said what if you're like so I never
said what if what if what if but I don't
think it'd change anything except fix
the shield to match the Japanese footage
maybe that'd be nice hey there we go
hi my name's Ryan and I was really
excited meet you both because you guys
are my childhood heroes I only like
heroes because of you guys they had I
like people guys because of you because
you did so well but not bad yeah we'll
see I don't like Lorde dragon I'd like
to use the original Green Ranger when
you first beat up the Power Rangers yeah
that was great
but my questions for you sir out of all
the raise you've been if you could only
pick one to be and that that it what
Ranger would you stay as if Tommy Allen
had the chance to be one probably the
pink gun weekends just kidding I like
the green when I first saw the Green
Green wasn't that color and 25 years ago
to be like oh I have a green car green
shoes great Green was kind of like risky
but I liked it I wouldn't change
anything it's so hard up so many
different Rangers and when you close
your eyes what Sammy I did the green I
did the white the Zeo did the turbo
black Dino Thunder and then Lord rockin
six maybe
thank you but the green I like the green
hey so my name is Jocelyn and this is
for Amy and I was wondering if you could
choose just one color for your costume
what would it be probably if I had if I
got to choose my I mean I like I like
the pink you look great in pink by the
way but I may be purple
was there a purple ranger I think there
wasn't a different season no am i right
mystic magic forest anyway that was my
favorite color maybe like a purple
purpley I do like that as yeah yeah
they're they there I don't know is there
orange Ranger no because it's a burnt
umber like though no every time I think
the open the orange I think of like the
annoying orange guy but they did I did
something for make-a-wish Foundation
you know Annoying Orange on YouTube
thing you know I'm talking about it's
just annoying I'll send you a link later
no no it's just a annoying orange thing
but but has brought did a thing for
make-a-wish Foundation and Hasbro
actually built Orange Ranger for a kid
that was a make-a-wish Foundation so
they presented them I think this weekend
I just did a video said keep fighting
his name's Tyler
so they actually Hasbro you know I made
a little orange ranger suit I didn't
know if there was an orange ranger was
there before ever so that's pretty cool
for him thank you there's a great
question thank you hi my name is Ronnie
Lee and my questions for the both of you
what was your best memory working on the
MMPR movie Oh in Australia we had fun
huh they say like that what do you mean
I don't know all these images were going
through my head I'm like we can't talk
about that we can't talk about that we
can't talk about that we're really a
bunch of kids in Australia for six
months we were there's like six months
because we need to film the movie twice
because the first dosia Marishka
Haggerty who is wonderful I don't know I
don't need do you know the story behind
that
do know the story behind that are you
allowed to tell yeah I mean she she was
hired for it and then we were doing so
you know Mariska Hargitay is right like
she was the highest-paid actress after
that Oh years but the original del SIA
she started with us and then they fired
then they got rid of her well because of
medical thing she had something wrong
with her stomach so so there was three
notice just to I'm you're talking about
Jane's Mansfield's daughter that was the
Mariska Hargitay Mariska yeah they hired
her after the first one because she was
sick and she couldn't do it so they
hired her and then they brought the
first one back that's all I know but
yeah that stuff went down because they
got rid of Mariska Hargitay anyway but
we originally trained over there six
months went to the story yeah so we were
there six months in Australia partying
and having fun I had never seen the Sun
come up like that before this bars don't
close and I was just like twenty-two no
that was lost him to a bar and then all
of a sudden you walk out and it's
daylight it was crazy
it's hard guys no I'm kidding it was so
fun I remember we closed the whole city
down I always wanted to do a movie that
was like you closed the city down I
don't know why I just always wanted like
do a movie in an airport or somewhere
really big not just Castaic Park we had
a little park mistake yeah I've read it
and be like Hawaii and this and we're
like oh and they're like Castaic
everything was at that park and it
wasn't even really a big thing so I
always wanted to like close the city
down or feel like I'm in a movie and
they did in Australia they you know
closed this whole city down I remember
standing there going wow this is super
cool but then they put your shields out
we have that visors we shot with the
visors out on that Street and then we
ended up putting the visors remember we
test shot it with the visors off they
took the bus that's a good memory my
hindsight is really I remember wrong
doing the shows I remember stuff but
they took the visors out and I remember
looking at John and it just didn't look
right
didn't look right we're like you could
see us know things crazy going from a TV
show which was very low-budget to this
like 35 million dollar movie which
suddenly it was like nicer craft service
it's like everything was but we still
filmed the show during the off times
over there a few episodes oh my god
you're right yeah off times why all
right in that film and TV shows anyway
we had a great time yeah it was fun
thanks for your question oh she needs
your friend you back you can do it it's
okay she wants the film oh okay she's
like get this for the gram I I guess my
question for you guys would be do you
guys plan on doing a movie together in
the future and will it have stunts in it
they're kind of like maybe your way oh
sorry I'm totally hearing what you're
saying but I was I have made me it
sparked a question of my own for Jason
which kind of has to do with what you're
talking about
what was I watching on the Instagram
what are you guys filming you and oh no
you are Jeff on all those guys we're
shooting something that kind of that
kind of a you have to wait to see Amy is
gonna be released in a week no don't
wait for is it a short what is it a
sizzle reel app or feature based off of
a feature
oh look am I asking too many questions
what's it gonna go oh it's all a
surprise you I only know this from
Instagram so they know as much as I know
yeah you know my so they're asking the
same questions okay okay
they didn't ask me to be in it whatever
you should write and direct a movie with
him in it well Jacobs directing cuz
you're directing all your spoken words
dunno I got Albert's directing that oh
the spoken word yeah because you know
what it's very it's hard to act indirect
at the same time especially yeah yeah it
looks really pretty all that stuff doing
good but that round table thing I was
even like I think Cameron is like I was
just as as an actor I played oh yeah
Shane played this guy played that guy
yeah so directing would be too much she
could direct me though but do we ever
plan on doing a movie I don't know I
mean if we did the Power Rangers thing
wish we had more it would have been
great for me naming to do another one or
no mmm Hasbro says that they're going to
but right now as you know how movie
making is is gonna take year and a half
to two years before they can fill any
well before they rate the script
opportunity there too because that's
what Hasbro wants to do they want to
build their Cinematic Universe so maybe
we'll get a ninja turtles and Power
Rangers on the big screen so the
Transformers and turn it over but me and
Amy should have been a mom or a dad to
the Green Ranger would have been fair we
we were citizen one yeah and I was
citizen too the whole time I thought I
was taking a picture I was taking a
selfie of them ourselves
I was like we're not taking us like
smile it was still fun to be a part of
it though it was fun I robbed everyone
thanks for your question all right let's
see if we can rapid-fire through the
rest of the line
hi there guys my name is David I'm a
huge fan of you guys
KDF obviously you were just there making
your intro ready to steal everybody's
girl Amy you were that guy I mean I'm
sorry you were the girl that every
little boy wanted it was really insane
you guys were game changing Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers opposite
phenomenon and my question is I do you
guys have like dreams or nightmares
being para characters still it gone away
I remember I had a really bad nightmare
it wasn't about being a Power Ranger but
is when we were doing the dude were you
part of the show and Universal Studios
or was that yeah when we did that show
we didn't realize how popular the show
was or I didn't or I don't know if they
did but they ended up selling out
universal Amphitheatre four times and
one day it was insane and we were
basically doing this like on stage sort
of rock star show like we come out and
flip our helmets off and the whole
stadium goes wow it was insane for
somebody for peak for kids who had never
really been on a stage before and been
in front of a crowd and I went home and
I had crazy crazy crazy nightmares for
like a week straight it really freaked
me out
it was it was almost like too much
attention and energy out in one moment I
know that doesn't really answer your
question but it just reminded me of that
but I think there's a point to that that
I think people are like oh you're an
actor guys when we're actors
we're on sets we're like a camera so
there's two different parts of this you
have the public speaking you have this
it was overwhelming I remember it was
just like whoa but I do karate so I'm
used to like taking stage and talking
but there's two different sides to
acting acting is not like where
everyone's watching we're not doing a
sitcom or you know anything like that
we're privately even though there's a
crew of 50 you get to know them you're
like family so it is a total two
different ways of thinking well you're
an actor and actress how can that freak
you out totally different screaming kids
like show after show after show I was
used to not used to that but used to
crowds but even me I was like oh my god
like it was just we went to Hawaii and
it was the same thing oh my did you guys
ever hear that story so when we were
doing Power Rangers back then we went to
Hawaii and they had announced on the
radio we were coming and we showed up
and they didn't they didn't know how
many people would actually come to the
airport and there was no security and
you know when you get to Hawaii and they
lay you they put flowers on you we got
off the plane and they started laying us
and lay and then opposite Jason turns
around and he looks at me
he has so many flowers on all I see is
the eyeballs and he's like it was so
scary and I like to say we almost got
laid to death and it's not that funny it
was crazy
mrs. Carey who are they there to see how
many people came to the airport like I
learned yet when Hawaii same thing we
mean her went to Florida I mean and part
of the reason Saban didn't like that is
because I still have news clippings it
was called power failure everywhere
because people were promised to see us
but there was 20,000 people and we
didn't know as an actor we just showed
up and did our stuff and cops had to
take us to like these you know and then
just think little kids but remember this
stampede on the gorge sent buzz down
there that's what's happening everyone's
trampling little kids are stuck you know
it's dangerous really does people think
that yeah you know so we had it it was a
crazy thing but as far as nightmares and
dreams you know until I read on this
thing that they're having to Vegas they
only last one to two seconds a dream I'm
just lost interest in having any dreams
or nightmares
they'd last one or two seconds it seems
like forever I wake up and I go I have
three movies stuck in my head that I
just dreamt No one second how does that
even work that's what it said in the
sign thing that dreams last one to two
seconds No so they said it can't be said
Google body thing over here you guys we
have 43 seconds thank you very one lets
40 if we can get either at really quick
rapid-fire answers can we do it new fan
here so I have this question are you
familiar with tokusatsu and and its
other series of side power range Nelson
very familiar with Tosca rapid mode I
made it are you familiar with kamen
rider or ultraman nope I don't
you know Kamen Rider did appear on
Mighty Morphin Power and just once no
smashed writer
yeah I'm just trying to rapid-fire guys
you're a bank by lunch now thank you for
your question
okay let's go quick word all right this
will be real quick on the power rangers
shows who was the biggest practical
joker not privacy hi
cool shirt I was wondering why did you
choose karate when I was 4 years old I
just was walking by a karate school and
saw this older lady doing karate and I
stayed with it my whole life and then I
wanted to play baseball true story and
my instructor said why throw ball when
why throw balls when you could throw
people and I was like okay I'll just
throw people I was stuck in karate my
whole life I loved it thank you thank
you I love that you're still so involved
with their schools and everything and
teaching and all that and the mayor of
power he wanted the mayor I saw I'm kpo
and so what kind of like the banjo while
you pick who's your favorite Power
Ranger would you pick yourself
be smart kid I would teach you something
I like take lessons from me Jason
attorney I was gonna see the Blue Ranger
because I know i yeah I I let you know
what the white one the white the White
Ranger okay that's different yeah that's
good that's me
I like the costume isn't it I wish you
guys know it's very it's good costume
with the gold and everything what's
yours
[Music]
oh gosh why the white one yeah me too
good choice
we like the same Ranger